أنت تعلم أن لدينا جهازًا مناعيًا
كان قادرًا على محاربة هذا الأمر
بمفردنا وهذا حقًا قوي حقًا كنت
هناك في Northwest's Bloodworks عندما
أصبحت إليزابيث شنايدر البالغة من العمر 37 عامًا
أول متبرع بالبلازما في ولاية واشنطن
لمساعدة الباحثين في جامعة واشنطن على دراسة الأجسام المضادة التي
تخبرها إليزابيث  لقد عانيت
مما تعتبره حالة خفيفة من
kovat 19 مرة أخرى في فبراير ، قالت إنها
مصابة بحمى 103 درجة ولكن لا توجد سعال
أو مشاكل في الجهاز التنفسي مهما كان في
البلازما وفي خلايا الدم البيضاء ، فهي
مفيدة للغاية لكليهما  البحث ولكن
أيضًا كعلاج لأشخاص آخرين
وأن البلازما المستعادة توجد بروتينات
تسمى الأجسام المضادة وقد تكون هذه البروتينات قادرة
على مساعدة الأشخاص المرضى
حاليًا.  أخبرتني Becky Haley with blood work
Northwest ، وكالة الجمع لهذه
الدراسة الجديدة ، أن شنايدر
وأي متبرع متطوع آخر يتم فحصه أولاً
بحثًا عن أي أمراض معدية أخرى قبل
أن يأتوا إلى هنا لإعطاء البلازما التي
يمكن استخدام البلازما لإنشاء علاجات
بأجسام مضادة لعلاج الآخرين.
التبرع الذي يتم نقله مباشرة
يمكن أن يعالج ثلاثة أو
أربعة أشخاص الآن بعد أن أصبحت الوحدة الأولى من
البلازما في المختبر ،
يبحث الباحثون بالتأكيد عن المزيد من البروتوكول
من المعاهد الوطنية للصحة الذي يسمح لنا بجمع
المتبرعين الذين تم استردادهم من الكوفات مرة واحدة في الأسبوع لمدة
تصل إلى 20  أسابيع مثل ثروة هائلة
من المعلومات
للباحثين والأطباء بالتأكيد ستنظر فرق
البحث في صحة هؤلاء
الأفراد وأعمار أولئك الذين
ينتجون الأجسام المضادة ومدى قوة تلك
الأجسام المضادة ومدى
استمرارها وكذلك جميع الأسئلة التي تطرحها هذه
الأبحاث  ستتطلع الفرق للإجابة على
رونالد لويس الذي جسّد الروح
المعنوية لنيو أورلينز التي قادها  تسعة
نوادي اجتماعية تستضيف مواكب ملاحم من
الخط الثاني حول حي لوار ناينث وارد ،
أخذ إعصار كاترينا
منزله لكن الأصدقاء يقولون إنه عاد
وأصبح مثل الأب الروحي
لثقافة نيو أورلينز ، لقد أظهر تعقيد نيو
أورلينز أفضل ما فينا في 18 مارس
تم نقل لويس إلى المستشفى
بعد يومين من وفاته ، ولم يكن حتى
يوم جنازته حيث تقول عائلته
إنهم علموا أنه مصاب
بفيروس كورونا الذي كان صادمًا وما
زلت أفكر حقًا حول هذا الأمر
.  كان
الشاب البالغ من العمر 68 عامًا يعاني من مرض السكري وكان
يتعافى من نوبة قلبية خفيفة في العام الماضي ،
لكنهم لم يعتقدوا أبدًا أن عدوى Cova 19
ستقضي على حياته.
يشكلون أكثر بقليل
من 70٪ من الوفيات الناجمة عن فيروس كورونا في
ميشيغان وإلينوي.
40٪ من
وفيات كوفات 19 هذا أمر بغيض
لكنه ليس غير متوقع وأريد
أن يفهم الجميع أن نيو أورلينز
هي صورة مصغرة لكل مركز حضري في
أمريكا د.  عمل كوري هيبرت
كطبيب في نيو أورلينز لمدة 25 عامًا ، حيث قام
بتفكيك العوامل المساهمة
في ارتفاع معدل الوفيات بين
الأمريكيين من أصل أفريقي ، فهناك مشكلات صحية أساسية
مثل أمراض القلب والسكري
، وإذا كنت تقود سيارتك في أنحاء نيو أورلينز ، فمن
السهل العثور على أحياء فقيرة حيث
لا يستطيع الناس الوصول إلى الرعاية الصحية ،
فالعديد من هذه الأحياء عبارة عن
صحارى طعام حيث قد يكون أفضل متجر بقالة
هو متجر زاوية ، إنها وصفة
لكارثة كما يقول د.  دب عندما
تتعرض للقمع المزمن عندما
تحاول بشكل مزمن الحصول على القصاصات
والفتات التي تقلل في الواقع من
قدرتك على الحصول على جهاز مناعي جيد
لأنك دائمًا في حالة قتال أو
طيران
باستمرار مع مستويات الكورتيزول
ومستويات الإبينفرين لأنك  لا
أعرف من أين ستأتي وجبتك التالية
من احتمالات قولك إنني سأحصل على
بعض البروكلي لتلك الوجبة التالية مقابل
أنك تعلم أن الهامبرغر يكلف
99 سنتًا والبروكلي 399
حفنة تعرف أن هذا هو  وضع الحياة أو
الموت بالنسبة لك وبعض الناس
لا يفهمون ذلك حقًا ، لذلك نحن لسنا
قلقين بشأنه على الإطلاق ، فهو دائمًا مزيف ،
ولكن نظرًا لأن فيروس كورونا بدأ ينتشر في
جميع أنحاء العالم ،
كانت نظريات المؤامرة على وسائل التواصل الاجتماعي
تنتشر بشكل أسرع
لا تستطيع الأقليات من أطفال الأقليات التقاط
مقاطع فيروسية كهذه ، ويخشى الخبراء الطبيون من أن
هذه المعلومات الخاطئة قد حافظت على بقاء هذه المعلومات
الخاطئة ويمكن أن تمنع كيث العديد
من الأمريكيين الأفارقة من إنقاذ حياتهم.
ممثل التشكيل إدريس إلبا ، الذي
أعلن في مارس / آذار عن إصابته
بفيروس كورونا ، توجه إلى وسائل التواصل الاجتماعي
للرد على المعلومات المضللة والتوقف عن
إرسال نظرية المؤامرة هراء
حول عدم قدرة السود على الإصابة بفيروس
كورونا أو أن كوفاتش 19 غبي ، إنه أمر
سخيف ، إنه أمر خطير للغاية  يحتاج الناس إلى
معرفة الحقائق التي يحتاجون إليها لفهم الحقيقة
حتى يتمكنوا من حماية أنفسهم ، والتوقف عن
إرسال هذه الأشياء ، إنه أمر
خطير للغاية بالنسبة للجميع
لأن فيروس كورونا الجديد اجتاح الصين لأول مرة ،
ودخل الملايين في
الإغلاق ومصانع مثل هذا
المصنع ووهو
لقد كنا كرة  أصبحت طابعات Tessa ثلاثية الأبعاد التي يتم تصنيعها في صندوق الألعاب
مظلمة ، حيث
تم إغلاق سلسلة التوريد الخاصة بنا تمامًا لمدة
شهرين ، ولكن مع إعادة تشغيل الصين ببطء ،
عاد إنتاج Baltus مرة أخرى ، وبما أن
الملايين في الولايات المتحدة يخضعون الآن للبقاء في
المنزل ، فقد شهد صندوق الألعاب ارتفاعًا في المبيعات.
يقول إنه من خلال حسن نية
عملائه على Facebook
وكان مجتمعنا يقودها حقًا ،
فقد أصبحت مجموعة Facebook منتدى عبر الإنترنت
شارك حول المستلزمات الطبية المختلفة
التي يمكن طباعتها في 3d
، حشدت جيني لي من جنوب كاليفورنيا
عائلتها بأكملها لمساعدتهم في
طباعة مقسمات لأجهزة
التهوية ، إنها عبارة عن بلاستيك بسيط ، حيث تعمل
القنوات على الهواء من مدخل واحد إلى
أنبوبين خارجين يحتمل أن يزيد
من استخدام  أجهزة التنفس الصناعي التي
تعاني بعض المستشفيات فيها من
نقص حاد في مهندس صناعة الطيران بولاية واشنطن ،
كريستيان باركر ،
يعمل من المنزل وينضم إلى هذا
الجهد مع أطفاله الثلاثة ، فأنا
لست محترفًا طبيًا على الإطلاق ، ولكن إذا كان
هذا شيئًا يمكنني تقديمه فهذا
يساعد  إنقاذ حياة شخص ما أو المساعدة في
التخلص من ضغوط الطبيب أو
التخلص من ضغوط الممرضة أو أي شخص آخر والمساعدة في
تلك الخطوط الأمامية إذا فعلت
ذلك ، فأنا بخير وسأستمر في القيام
بذلك حتى يكون جهاز التنفس الصناعي هذا  تستخدم من قبل
العديد من المرضى تقول هيلين شون في جامعة جونز
هوبكنز إن العديد من
المستشفيات في الولايات المتحدة التي تفتقر إلى
أجهزة التنفس الصناعي الكافية تحقق الآن نجاحًا
مع  جهاز تقسيم Y بسيط ، لذلك عادة ما
يكون لديك جهاز تنفس واحد مريض واحد
ويمكن للطبيب تغيير الإعدادات
لمنح المريض ما يحتاجه بالضبط
ولكن ما يحدث عندما يكون لديك عدة
مرضى على جهاز تشريح واحد
ليس لديك نفس القدر من
التحكم الدقيق في  المرضى ، لذا فهي
وفريقها يعملون الآن بسرعة لتطوير
نوع متقدم من المقسمات ، وفي
الوقت نفسه تقول إن المقسمات البسيطة
المطبوعة في المنازل في جميع أنحاء الولايات المتحدة
تبدو فعالة وتسمح للأشخاص
من جميع الأعمار بالبقاء في المنزل والمساعدة وأنا
شحنت عشر وحدات لسيدة في
كاليفورنيا تقوم بالتنسيق مع
مستشفيات في زيمبابوي وغانا أيضًا ،
لذلك نحن الآن نصل إلى مواقع دولية
تتلقى عائلة لي الآن طلبًا للحصول على
عناصر مطبوعة أخرى مثل مقاطع s
لأقنعة الوجه التي لم يرَ أحدًا فيروس كورونا
قادمًا  يتم تصوير سلاسل التوريد في الوقت الحالي
ولكن أي شخص لديه طابعة ثلاثية الأبعاد قادر
على بناء هذه الأشياء في المنزل الآن
يقول فولتا إن الأمر لا يتعلق بالأشخاص الذين يشترون
منتجه في  حقيقة أنه صنع
الكود المصدري لمقاطع التقسيم وحتى
أقنعة الوجه للأطفال مجانًا ومتاح
لأي علامة تجارية للطابعات ثلاثية الأبعاد لاستخدامها
من مصنع في الصين إلى العائلات في
الولايات المتحدة.  إنشاء خطوط التجميع الخاصة بهم في المنزل
جهدًا عالميًا لإعادة
David Culver CNN Shanghai